sure it's nice to see actor starring in
roles they were almost destined to play
Robert Downey jr. is Tony Stark
Sigourney Weaver is Ellen Ripley Arnold
Schwarzenegger as The Terminator
Sylvester Stallone as Rocky but
sometimes an actor only has a shot at an
iconic role after someone else turns it
down although everything worked out in
the way it was supposed to in the end we
still can't help wondering what could
have been if these actors didn't say no
no number one Thomas Jane as Don Draper
when we think of Mad Men we think of the
dashing and duplicitous Jon Hamm but
Hamm told Marc Maron on the WTF podcast
back in 2011 that the role which gave
him his break almost went to someone
else they went to Thomas Jane for it and
they were told that Thomas Jane does not
do television mm-hmm whether or not
that's true
Jane later did take a regular television
role starring on HBO's hung for three
seasons number two Matthew Broderick and
John Cusack as Walter White
after earning sitcom fame and malcolm in
the middle' bryan cranston made a huge
career leap when he was cast as science
teacher turned meth kingpin Walter White
on Breaking Bad while show creator Vince
Gilligan always wanted Cranston The
Hollywood Reporter revealed that AMC
wasn't interested
instead the network wanted Matthew
Broderick or John Cusack to take on the
lead role luckily for Cranston both
baby-faced actors passed and after execs
saw Cranston's dramatic work in the
x-files everyone was on board before
else number three Emily Blunt as Black
Widow Scarlett Johansson totally and
literally kills as the Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of Natasha Romanov aka
the Black Widow
but the role was almost given to Emily
Blunt who had to back out she's fine
with it though as she explained the
Screen Rant quote I didn't do it at the
time because it wasn't the right time
and it was contracted to do something
else but Scarlett has done such a
phenomenal job she's at number four and
that Bening as Catwoman
for many Michelle Pfeiffer is the only
Catwoman
having stolen the show in Tim Burton's
Batman Returns but as blaster points out
the role was originally intended for
Annette Bening who dropped out when she
became pregnant with her first child
right before shooting started Pfeiffer
had been gunning for the role from the
moment she'd read the script so she
slept right in
number five Will Smith as neo it's true
Will Smith turned down the iconic sci-fi
action flick The Matrix everything's
turned out just fine with The Fresh
Prince since then but he explained his
decision to Wired in 2004 quote The
Matrix is a difficult concept of pitch
in the pitch I just didn't see it
I watched Kiana's performance and very
rarely do I say this but I would have
messed it up I would have absolutely
messed up the matrix instead he saved
that honor for the wild wild west
number six Dougray Scott as Wolverine
originally dug risk Scott was tapped to
play Wolverine in the original 2000 film
x-men but after scheduling conflicts
with his role in Mission Impossible to
the gig went to Hugh Jackman now one of
the biggest stars in the world
no hard feelings though Scott told The
Daily Record quote I like you he's a
really lovely guy it wasn't as if he
stole it off me basically my movie ran
over and I had to pull out speaking of
Jackman number 7 Hugh Jackman as James
Bond with dr. Scott we had someone
passing on Wolverine to take on the role
of a spy here we have Wolverine passing
on the role of the most iconic spy in
the world
Entertainment Weekly reports the [ __ ]
incision back when he was filming the
second x-men film Jackman would've
replaced Pierce Brosnan after die
another day but Jackman didn't feel that
it was the right time still he remarked
that it was a very hard role to pass up
comic geeks kept on Wolverine and the
rest of the world got Daniel Craig
number 8 Tom Hanks has Jerry Maguire
writer and director Cameron Crowe
originally wrote Jerry Maguire with Tom
Hanks in mind
unfortunately Hanks was a little too old
to play the young upbeat sports agent
and Tom Cruise made famous Hanks
declined the project after reading an
early draft of the script speaking with
Empire magazine in April of 1997 crow
said Hanks past because he didn't like
the film's romantic subplot between
Maguire and Renee Zellweger's Dorothy
Boyd number 9 Pamela Anderson as Dana
Scully
before agents Mulder and Scully started
searching for aliens in the x-files Fox
approached Baywatch star panel Anderson
to play a female FBI agent Entertainment
Weekly reported that Gillian Anderson
was the one revealed Fox's original
choice for the character quote she was
someone who was more familiar to them in
terms of what was on TV at the time they
were looking for someone busty or taller
like e'er than me
luckily Pam passed on the role and
Jillian's intelligent but skeptical
demeanor helped provide a great contrast
to David Duchovny's Mulder leading the
show to 62 Emmy nominations and finally
number 10 jean-claude van damme as the
predator Believe It or Not the muscles
from Brussels was originally supposed to
play the alien hunter in the 1987
classic predator jean-claude van damme
arrived on set thinking that he was
going to use his martial art skills to
fight a bunch of soldiers it wasn't too
long after that when he found out he'd
be wearing a giant silly monster suit
instead Van Damme ran around in a red
rubber suit for a while but he hated the
role after all it was a hot suit and the
movie was filmed in a Mexican jungle and
he thought it'd be playing a human
eventually Van Damme volunteered to body
double for Arnold Schwarzenegger and a
few of the movies explosive stunts
instead the predator suit was later
redesigned for Kevin Peter Hall whose
near seven-foot tall height made him
tower over his co-stars and was only
slightly more intimidating than Hall's
other most notable role thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which star you'd most
like to see in the role they turned down